everyone this is Kevin from the test
website comm and today we're going to be
going over a nice little opening defense
for the Queen's Gambit and so if you
don't like to play the Queens gambit
accepted line today we're going to be
going over a Queens gambit declined line
and that is the slop defense we're going
to be going over a lot of different
variations this is very popular in GM
play because there are so many different
variations in this lob defense we're
going to go over some of the main points
of some of the most popular variations
that you will see the slob defense
starts out with pawn to d4 pawn to d5
both trying to control the center with
their pawns from here White's going to
play pawn to c4 and then black is going
to play pawn to c6 instead of playing
pawn to e6 instead he's first going to
play pawn to c6 trying not to block off
his LightSquared bishop and at the same
time protecting his pawn on d5 now there
are a lot of variations one of the first
ones we'll touch on is the exchange
variation and it's pawn captures on d5
and black responds capturing on d5 and I
really feel that this is one of the
least exciting variations of the opening
and for this a lot of times you actually
instead of c6 first you'll see the semi
Slav which is e six first and then c6
will eventually come into the mix and
will actually go over the sim Slav in a
nother video since it's a completely
different defense in itself but the Slav
continues with c6 and the exchange
variation which we talked about is less
common but we'll go over the mainline
and some of the main variations that you
will see from the mainline and the main
line continues with Knight to f3 trying
to control the center development of his
knight and from here blacks going to do
the same he's going to develop his
Knight to f6
and then White's going to bring his
Knight to c3 and from here blacks going
to go and start taking pieces he is
going to take on c4 and from here it's a
very important move white needs to play
a four and what this does is it prevents
black from playing his pawn to b5 now a
lot of players if they're very
aggressive like myself they may even try
and move like e4 this is the Slav gambit
and this is offering up this pawn back
so that black can play pawn to b5
holding on to this pawn but it's really
tough to say if white has adequate
compensation for this pawn I instead if
you're playing white and you do sleeve
see the Slav I would actually recommend
just applying the a4 pawn to a4 and what
this does is it doesn't allow black to
play his pawn to b4 but what it does do
is if you can see anytime your opponent
plays you want to see the space that he
left and this pawn on the a file is
really going to be used to defend this
b4 palm but once it comes up to a four
it can no longer defend this B 4 square
so this B 4 square is going to be a
major theme throughout the Slav defense
so if you're playing the mayline and you
do come across this always be aware that
blacks going to be looking at this B 4
square and it's going to try to hold on
to it and white in turn is going to try
to make sure that black does not hold on
to it the entire game so play can
continue from here
Bishop to f5 and what Bishop to f5 does
is a couple things one it develops his
LightSquared Bishop so from here black
can continue to play his pawn to e6
without trapping is LightSquared Bishop
and at the same time that prevents white
from playing e4 why we really like to
play e4 with his pawn putting his pawn
in a nice central square but at the same
time at the discovered attack on this c4
pawn with our pawn not being able to be
on b5 blacks going to lose this pawn
it's all of the matter of how white
takes it and he would really like to
play E for getting great central cans
control with his pawns at the same time
taking on c4 with his Bishop right here
now since why can't play efore in this
situation because our bishop is here on
f5 instead you'll see pawn to e3 and
what this does is two things one it
allows to open up this bishop this
LightSquared bishop at the same time
they connect these pawns now eventually
white would like to play his pawn to e4
but he can't right away because our
bishop but he would like to play e4
because he would solidify the middle
with his pawns at the same time right
now he's blocking off his dark squared
bishop on c1 and he would like to open
that up so right away he's going to play
III and from here likes going to play e6
now anytime you see pawns on e6 and c6
eventually the knight is going to be
played from b8 to d7 this is just the
normal development for the night if a
pawn is on c6 and ecigs and we'll see
this later in the game but what this
pawn to e6 does is it allows our dark
square Bishop to get into the action
remember we'd really like to bring our
dark square Bishop to this b4 square so
from here
White's going to play Bishop takes on c4
centralizing his bishop and at the same
time equalizing a material from here
we're going to continue with our game
plan we're going to bring our Bishop to
b4 this is going to be a great square
for our Bishop for the time being we're
pinning down this Knight to the King and
at the same time the pawns it would
normally kick this Bishop out would be
on CNA and both of those pawns can no
longer kick this Bishop out so for a why
our bishops going to be here until we
don't want them to anymore
now from here you'll see White Castle
and he castles King side because his
Knights being pinned and he doesn't want
his knight being pinned anymore so he's
just going to get his King to the Castle
kingside to get it more King safety and
from here we're going to do exactly what
we talked about before we're going to
bring our Knight to d7 and this is a
great development square not King coming
to the middle anytime he wants next
weekend Castle kingside if we want for
King safety but this is going to be the
main line that you'll see in the Slav
very often and from here there's a few
things that you want to keep in mind
black eventually would like to play a
move
like to see five or five trying to break
up the middle and white would really
like to play a move like 'if or trying
to gain center control so it really
comes down to these different themes of
what both sides are trying to do black
the entire game tries to hold on to this
b4 pawn excuse me this B Foursquare and
at the same time if you see the white
knight come to h4 a lot of times players
will try to get the bishops away from
your opponent you can leave your Bishop
here a lot of times players will not
only allow the other team to take their
Bishop but let's say black castles King
side and the knight takes on f5 a lot of
black players like to let black skip
white do this so when they recapture
they have more control with this efore
Square remember the center is very
important so if we have more pressure on
this efore Square with our knight on f6
and our pawn on f5 this is very strong
for black so these are a few ideas that
you'll want to take a look at when
looking at the Slav defense especially
in the mainline another variation that
you're going to see in the Slav offense
is the simple decline line and so I want
to go over it because there are a few
missteps that a lot of people make and
so I want to go over just exactly how
you should approach it when you come
across it so Slav starts out with d4 d5
c5 and c6 and from here White's going to
play Knight to f3 and Black's gonna play
Knight to f6 now there's two moves that
white can make we went over the c3 move
but a lot of times you'll see the white
pawn come to e3 wide away he's not
trying to bring his knight into the
action yet instead he's freeing up his
Bishop so if black takes on c4 he
doesn't have to worry about playing a4
and worrying about this B force where
the entire game which a lot of white
players don't like to worry about
instead he plays III so after black
takes white can simply come down capture
with his bishop on c4 and he doesn't
have to worry about this b4 square or
his pawn on a for the entire game so if
you see this keep in mind because
if he does play this you don't have to
take on c4 I was just showing you but
from here your bishop can come to f5 and
this is going to be a very good square
for your bishop from here if white
captures on c5 and we recapture with our
pawn then we have great central control
we can now bring our pawn to e6 our
LightSquared Bishop is not blocked in we
can get our dark square Bishop into the
game we can Castle kingside and black is
going to have a very good game from here
the problem arises if you're expecting
e3 and don't play accordingly let's say
white plays d4 we play d5 they play C 4
and after c6 they play Knight f3 Knight
f6 and now instead they play Knight to
c3 which is the main line that we talked
about now let's say we try to bring our
bishop into the action on f5 now
remember before we didn't play this as
our first move but let's say we try to
play it now thinking that it was III now
from here this is going to be a huge
mistake the Queen can now come to b3 for
white and they're going to have a huge
advantage see now that he has three
attackers on this one pawn his pawn his
night in his queen and at the same time
he's attacking this pawn on b7 black
can't defend both of these without
losing a tempo he's going to have to
move his Bishop back to c8 and this is
going to be very bad for black so keep
in mind that if he plays his knight then
I would go ahead and move along with the
main theme that we talked about earlier
in the video and if he plays III then
it's going to be safe for you to play
your Bishop to f5 but not otherwise make
sure that you always have all your
different variations in your mind so
that you don't play the wrong thing and
get completely messed up so this is the
Slav variation hope you guys learned a
lot on this Queen's game decline line if
you haven't already please subscribe
thanks for watching and I'll see you
guys next video